que ce soit les abribus les bancs ou
encore les aires de jeux pour enfants
depuis le début de la semaine ses agents
d'une société privée s'emploie à
nettoyer absolument tous les espaces
publics de la ville de suresnes dans les
hauts-de-seine masqués gantés et vêtus
d'une combinaison translucide des
équipes armées d'un produit bio anti
bactérien safer dès le petit matin
autour des endroits pouvant être en
contact avec des personnes porteuses du
virus
les vitres il faut le nettoyer comme ça
non en fait en gros vous fait si le
produit est ensuite vous devez quand
même passé le torch ans après nous voilà
c'est ça surtout seules les vitres comme
ça voilà c'est le siège comme ça encore
on va le nettoyer et on le suit on ne
laisse pas comme ça aujourd'hui on fait
là demain on se prend ce soit on va
faire comment on va continuer le travail
ce n'est pas que cet endroit pour ses
hommes
ce travail de nettoyage est aussi un
moyen de se sentir utile
c'est très important
j'ai des petits enfants qui viennent
chez nous ils touchent des choses ici et
après si je tombais malade
c'est ce que je sais bien et a un mental
cox depuis quelques jours la fréquence
de nettoyage a été sensiblement augmenté
la mairie souhaite profiter de cette
période de confinement vous avez fait
les
on à proximité d'un collège dont il ya
beaucoup d'enfants qui posent leurs
mains sur ses rampes ces barrières et
donc je souhaitais qu'on insiste sur sur
le geste barrière justement mais alors
là les écoles sont fermées les collèges
sont fermées donc après d'enfants a
priori heureusement ccc pour nous aussi
la possibilité de nettoyer sereinement
on connaît pas techniquement la durée de
vie de ceux des bactéries ou du virus et
donc ça permet un nettoyage de la ville
et puis aussi bas si ça peut rassurer
tant mieux de toute façon il faut
rassurer les français
les agents ont reçu la consigne
d'insister tout particulièrement sur les
zones touchées par les voyageurs une
opération qui semble rassurer les
riverains se rassurent en se rassurant
surtout pour ceux qui ont l'obligation
d'aller au boulot
moi j'ai fait le choix d'y aller
aujourd'hui après je vois qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de monde non plus dans l'erreur
je pense que tout le monde respecte le
confinement c'est bien cette
désinfection des espaces publics
devraient se poursuivre tant que la
pandémie ne sera pas endiguée le virus
quant à lui se propage à grande vitesse
rappelons le on a dépassé la barre des
10000 cas dans l'hexagone